[Music]
i'm not i'm not a big fan of steve jobs
personally what are you talking about i
just i don't know i just don't
understand
why what the big deal was with that guy
i don't get it he's like edison i don't
know he invented all this stuff
everybody what are you talking about did
he did he
it's like did he sit down and like i'm
gonna invent the iphone and just sat
there soldering
possibly welding right didn't he have
like a crew of guys helping him out sure
maybe he did
why when he went to those nerdfests
didn't he have like like a
like a chorus of scientists behind him
who helped him out too
he walked out like he was tesla like
tapping into electricity i think he just
kind of like
told people what to invent like he just
kind of came in like i want my whole
music collection
in that phone get on it
look at all these nameless faceless guys
yeah made it happen yeah and then they
have the big nerd concert and he goes
out there by himself
no belts you know sneakers on i just
didn't buy it
it's the craziest rant it isn't though
craziest rant
i don't like and the way they do i walk
out on this show with all the writers
and stuff no and i never will
all right but you don't
just the way you advertised jesus gandhi
me
i just thought that was a little the
first one never worked and four months
later all right here he is the one that
worked yeah it bugged me
do you think i was like trashing the
president or something you guys are
really like pulling back it's worse than
that for people everyone's got an iphone
you know
hey look no i can't say that i'll just
say he's gone they still came out with
another one
right that's true right
oh look with david lee roth
left van halen could eddie not play
guitar anymore
you know what i'm saying right that's a
good analogy